right guilty pleasure um that craps gone
Oh No you're so pathetic frozen yogurt
yes yeah yeah some chocolate no whatever
you're holding whatever you're pumping
hair and makeup Karen hey it's not a
secret recording no other she can throw
together a cheese card like you can't
believe
[Music]
germs yeah yeah I don't know what
happened when did that happen
I don't know cuz I used to be a real
dirty bird and now I may be it's because
that because oh because I cleaned my act
up I'm cleaned interact up and now it's
all about clean clean clean don't touch
that
yeah hotel floors do you do ever when
you were a kid and you'd go in to buy
shoes you weren't wearing socks did you
put those little did you go into that
basket that's coxeter you I don't know
you know you know picky eater likes well
I mean what love a cheeseburger D you're
not you're not precious like you're not
beat hey hey feet can t to be whole
[Music]
right laughing so hard she's crying oh
that's a good one yeah but I also love
this some monkey with hands-on eyes yeah
but her bitmoji though oh that's it
mochi sees really she's a Jedi Knight
with all that stuff she says all okay
90s nice always show up I'm gonna be
there not early but I said I'm not gonna
go to the party
that's probably we're gonna call me
[ __ ] she's gonna run the let's hang out
at my house company yeah I do like to
throw a dinner party it's real cozy
situation over there ready for the next
take and she just runs through the six
phases that I'm gonna make during scene
perhaps and in what order
yeah she goes ten one ten one is code
for PB out the Tiki unless it's a big
scene a lot of water then it's a 10 it's
a 10 dude Joe never now did you know
that